وبالفعل ونسمع ايضا اشتباكات حتى بالاسلحه
الخفيفه والرشاش التي تدور رحاها منذ اكثر
من ساعه وكانت قد دخلت على خط هذه
المواجهه ايضا مروحيه عسكريه اسرائيليه من
نوع اباتشي التي حامت في اجواء جباليا
ومخيمها واطلقت ايضا الرصاص من العيار
الثقيل باتجاه مواقع بعينها هناك وكانه
كان ذلك غطاء ناريا تغطي فيه القوات
البريه على الارض ونحن نرى هذا الدخان
المتصاعد في منطقه جباليا منذ اكثر من
ساعتين بعد قصف مدفعي طال تلك ال المنطقه
ونحن نشاهد ايضا بان هذه العمليه ما زالت
مستمره نحن ما زلنا نسمع اصوات ال
الاشتباكات بالاسلحه الخفيفه
وبالاسحار الشاشه وهذا يعني بان هنالك
قتالا دار
ان معركه ما زالت تجري على الارض في تلك
المنطقه رغم ان الجيش الاسرائيلي كان
يتحدث في الايام الماضيه عن انه سيطر
ناريا وسيطر عملات على مخيم جباليا وعلى
المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه لكن عندما
يقول الجيش الاسرائيلي بانه سيطر ناريا
وسيطر لاتيا يعني ليس هنالك حاجه لان
يستخدم ال المدفعيه الاسرائيليه لدك هذا
المناطق او استخدام الدبابات لضرب هذه
المناطق ولا حتى سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي
لانه عندما يقول بانه يسيطر على تلك
المناطق هذا يعني بان جنوده موجودون على
على الارض ولكن يبدو ان الواقع هو غير ذلك
تماما وان اشتباكات ما زالت تجري وجها
لوجه في اكثر من موقع في تلك المناطق نعم
لو تسمح لمراسل الجزيره كذلك في خبر عاجل
يفيد عن سقوط عشرات الشهداء في قصف
اسرائيلي على جب باليه بسبب الياس هذه
الاشتباكات التي كنا نتحدث عنها
الاشتباكات الجاريه هناك وبالتالي هناك
تعذر للوصول للمصابين في الشوارع من اجل
اسعافهم اعود اليك مجددا
الياس نعم بالفع بالفعل وال الواضح بان
هنالك قصف مدفعي ياتي ايضا من المنطقه
الموجودين فيها في غلاف غزه هنالك قصف
مدفعي شديد يطال مناطق اي مختلف في جباليا
حتى المناطق الشرقيه الان نرى ايضا سحب
الدخان التي تنبعث حتى من المناطق
الشماليه ل ل جباليا ويركز عليها مصورنا
لبيب الان اذا اكثر من موقع ليس فقط هذا
الموقع الرئيسي لانبعاث سحب الدخان الذي
كان قبل ساعتين لكن واضح بان هنالك مركز
اخر لا اطلاق هذه القذائف المدفعيه نشاهد
في اماكن اخرى في المناطق الشماليه
الشرقيه حتى لمدين مدينه غزه بان الجيش
الاسرائيلي بدا يستخدم ايضا قنابل الدخان
ربما هنالك صعوبه في رؤيتها بسبب احوال
الجو العاصفه والما طره لكن واضح بان
الجيش الاسرائيلي اعاد ليستخدم ايضا
القنابل الدخانيه في المناطق الشرقيه
القريبه من السياج الامني هذا ربما يعطي
مؤشرا على ان الجيش الاسرائيلي يحاول ان
يقيم ستارا دخانيه لسحب قواته او لتحرك
قواته العسكريه في تلك المناطق او ل ربما
اخراج وانتشال جرحى وقتلى في صفوف الجيش
الاسرائيلي وهذا ما شاهدناه في الايام
الماضيه الان الزميل لبيب يركز على تلك ال
المنطقه بالتحديد هي المناطق الشماليه
الشرقيه لمدينه غزه واضح بان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يستخدم اي قنابل الدخان هذه
لاقامه هذا الستار وحجم الرؤيه عن
المقاومه الفلسطينيه عندما يكون الجيش
الاسرائيلي بحاجه الى هذا هذا الساتر
الدخاني هذا يعني بان هنالك معارك موجوده
على الارض هنالك تحركات تجري على الارض و
ربما اشتباكات عنيفه وضاره كما يوصفها حتى
الجيش الاسرائيلي في بياناته العسكريه اذا
نحن في اليوم ال8 للحرب ومنذ ال 26 من
اكتوبر عندما بدات الجيش الاسرائيلي بدا
اجتياحه البري كان يتحدث عن انه يسيطر
ناريا وانه توغل
وتمكن من الوصول الى معاقل حركه حماس
ومعاقل ال الجهاد الاسلامي وغيرها من
المنظمات الفلسطينيه التنظيمات الفلسطينيه
لكن واضح بان السيطره الناريه على البا
على الارض ليست موجوده بمعنى ان الحسم
العسكري على الارض ليس موجودا حتى لو ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي توغل في اكثر من موقع
وفي اكثر من مكان ودخل الى الاحياء ودمرها
لكن هنالك مواجهه عنيفه وهنالك معارك
ضاريه لا تتوقف وحتى انه في المناطق التي
كان يفترض ان الجيش الاسرائيلي قد بدا
فيها عمليه التمشيط وعمليه التمشيط هي
عمليه تاتي بعد المعارك الكبيره عمليه
التمشيط التي يستهدف من خلالها الوصول الى
مستودعات الاسلحه ويستهدف من خلالها
الوصول الى فوهات الصواريخ التي تطلق
الصواريخ باتجاه ال مدن اسرائيليه الكبرى
والعمق الاسرائيلي لكن الجيش الاسرائيلي
يجابه في تلك ال المواقع بمقاومه شرسه لا
يعرف من اين تخرج له كما يبدو لاننا نرى
بان الجيش الاسرائيلي في اي مقاطع الفيديو
حتى التي ينشرها يشير الى هذه العمليات
النوعيه التي يخرج فيها المقاومون
الفلسطينيون ويشتركون مع الجيش الاسرائيلي
من مسافه صفر ومن مسافه قريبه وواضح بان
فتوحات الانفاق والانفاق الهجوميه
الموجوده في داخل قطاع غزه والتي يب يبدو
ان الجيش الاسرائيلي ليس لديه المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه الكافيه عن اماكن وجودها
وعن عددها وعن عمقها وهو يكتشف ذلك من
خلال هذه العمليه البريه وهذا يدلل على ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي لديه ضعف استخباراتي
هائل في تحديد القدره العسكريه ال التابعه
لحركه حماس تحت الارض بمعنى شبكه الانفاق
الهجوميه التي يستخدمها الان رجال
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في تسديد هذه الضربات
للجيش الاسرائيلي